only two candidates remain one final
task stands in the way of Hannah and
Anthony as they dream of taking home
Samuels 20,000 pounds cash prize 11
candidates have fallen by the wayside
but can the two finalists hold their
nerve as the race to be crowned champion
unravels in this thrilling series finale
have been pointed out and pound
transferred in to let us know in the
comments below who you think will win
the competition and who's Samuel will
transfer twenty thousand pounds to live
in front of their eyes it's the grand
final of the eviction
so one week after leaving the castle we
captured with Anthony to see Weiss be
not perceived since the last board room
all right so tell me a bit about what's
what's going on that's the suite them so
basically what I've been looking for is
properties that I can find below market
value to do buy refurbish refinance with
so I found seven properties but anybody
else have book viewings on two of well
one of them actually and I got off of
this second one set eight in total
[Music]
[Music]
first make sure on the works with her I
think I'll meet send some pictures of
the seller to the Builder just to see
what his viewpoint is whether it's going
to affect any kind of rising damp on the
property I think how what do you think
of the damn ball of rubber though so I
think it looks like it's coming up from
the base I don't know a quote to get
that fixed if I'm honest with you
normally about 4,000 pounds 5,000 pounds
of believed to get the damn course done
in in something like that so but I'll
need to send off and get a quote for
that I think the property exclude the
main shell of the property kitchen the
kitchen new carpets throughout the house
imagine we could probably do the work on
that for about six thousand you know
what the big turn offs for me
what's that for that yeah because next
doors grapple isn't it clearly my
property and crew that I used are
currently owned used to be my home of
residence I've now moved out of that and
bought this new house
so this house I've decided to rent out
and my perfect idea for this house is
I've done a lot of work to it was to
have a really nice family move in there
whilst doing some work on the house has
a lady come across the road
and asked me if I was going to rent it
so I explained to her I was and she she
told me a story that she was on the
council waiting list she'd been really
struggling to get a house she's got two
children and actually that they were
only gonna give her a two-bedroom house
which meant that in two years time
they'd have to try and move again
because one of the child become too old
and they couldn't live together in the
same room so I let how come and have a
look around my house and she just fell
in love with it and said it was the
perfect house for her and after talking
to her I said to her actually you're the
perfect tenant you're exactly what I'm
looking for and for you to have fell on
my doorstep is fantastic so we're hoping
to meet tomorrow and she's gonna sign
the contracts and her in a part and
they're the children they're gonna be
able to live in my house and build some
new memories which is fantastic
so happy with everything
excellent well there's the keys and
really hope you enjoy the house thank
you so much and I'll see you soon yet
another great home for a growing family
Anthony proving there that if you don't
cut corners and you do things right you
can find the perfect tenants and still
make money with property let's have a
chat with his family to see if he's a
squeaky bloody clean as we've made him
out I honestly when he told me about
Ian's property I was honestly just
basically just support I was just like
if you think it's right and you want to
do it then go for it because I'm not
going to stop you like I still don't
understand too much or anything really
like some things he says to me do go
over my head but he always asked me
things I'm like if you think it's great
then do it so then I just I support him
with whatever but what he's big biggest
weakness is sometimes it's I think he
overthinks things too much like him
he'll think like something he hasn't
done isn't good enough and then he might
then try and make it better but then
actually over complicating it when it
was already great because he just has
that self-doubt sometimes I think that's
what his biggest weakness is so be
honest I was very cynical at the
beginning and said you know really do
your homework before you go into this I
just thought it was hard selling at the
beginning to be honest I was a bit
apprehensive to say the least I've
watched him along the way getting more
and more enthusiastic about the journey
and he really excited about the
different things and I've seen pictures
of the buildings and the rooms that he's
transformed and I thought there's more
to this that meets the eye really I need
to really look into this so I started
watching some of Samuels YouTube videos
and I thought this isn't what I thought
it was so I then phoned up Anthony one
day and I said guess what I'm going to a
crash course which he was really shocked
about
and and it was like why and I said
because I want to see for myself you
know and I did go along to the crash
course and I found it absolutely
fantastic it's not about the money with
Anthony it's a it's about wanting to to
not win he's not even the winning of it
it just wants to achieve it he wants to
I think he wants people to be proud of
him you know and so I don't really think
he's doing it for the money so if I'm
perfectly honest I don't think it is the
money he's doing it for it's just for
him and his self-esteem that's why he's
doing it because he wants to you know
prove to probably his family that you
know he can do this you know because
he's very very family-orientated on
tania's and his family made the world to
him you know so I don't think it is
about the money
I really don't being Anthony's biggest
strength is being able to to talk to
people and get his message across in a
very very polite he's not he's not pushy
you know and and I think he's he makes
people feel at ease very very easily you
know and he if he's going to do
something he research it so he's going
to say something he can old use and on
his art and say I know what I'm telling
you is true and I think people read
through that with a lot of people don't
they you know they can see a bit of a
scam artist sticking out like a sore
thumb and and it doesn't put that image
across if it's all whatever comes out of
his mouth true
Anthony absolutely is the Dell blue
Stafford he always says this time next
year we'll be millionaires
[Applause]
I think Anthony has managed to make it
through to the final because of his
absolute determination nothing will get
in Antony's way he can be quite ruthless
but he's extremely eloquent in how he
engages other people into his projects
very conscientious and absolutely knows
what his end result will be I'm very
excited and very anxious ham is a very
strong candidate and I think it's great
that both her and I are in the finals
because I think we both deserve to be
there we've put a lot of effort and work
in I would love to win the competition
and I think I'm exactly right to win the
competition because I think what I'll do
with the money will help provide more
great houses of people and I'm so really
excited and I just hope that when Samuel
sees what I'm going to do with the
strategy he'll pick me to win
Antony I'm so incredibly proud of you
before getting through to the final I
wish you all the very best of luck
because I absolutely know that you can
win this hands down good luck good luck
Antony was so proud of you keep up the
good work we know you can do this all
the best and just look to the future I
really wish you all the best for the
final and I'm behind you a hundred and
ten percent and I am so so proud of you
so that is answer D will mark for the
record one of the nicest guys I've ever
met in my entire life but let's take a
trip over to the valleys and get an
insight into what Hannah mills has been
up to the only candidate to win every
single task on the eviction and probably
the bookies favorite to lift the title
so here we are in wonderful sunny Wales
we're actually having to stand under a
tree at the minute because it's raining
and it's really quite heavy we're in
front of the beautiful de Carr house
yeah Trudy you have to move on so Hannah
please just all by just explain briefly
of what your business plan was again
sure so basically my business plan is
three steps over three years first step
is to have five service accommodation
apartments in Cambridge second step is
to refurb my house with some of the
money that I make from the five
apartments and pull out even more money
into a pot of pot cash and then the
third step is to invest that pot of cash
that I'd go up for the service
combination apartment and my house to
invest in buy-to-let properties in
glorious Southwest even thought rains
here all the time even though it rains
it's like when you'd when I draw from
England and Wales it started raining
it's like welcome to Wales it's raining
you know everyone says that and to be
honest with you it's not great that it's
raining right now I swear to you it was
actually sunny last week I promise you
believe it believe it or not the rental
market is actually quite strong here so
how have you been implementing your
business plan so tomorrow we'll go into
Cambridge you'll see the five apartments
you'll meet the landlord who's also a
mini developer and Cambridge that I've
built up a relationship with which is
cool so you'll see them and then today
you're going to see a by refurb project
in South Wales and sort of the
possibility of what I want to invest in
and and yet you'll get to know Cambridge
a bit tomorrow and basically what I plan
to do is take you for every step of my
business plan so you can see where I am
going and how I'm going out there and
you've got the the twenty thousand
pounds spent pretty much I yeah I mean
if I just invested in the five service
of accommodation apartments myself then
it's roughly around about seventeen a
half grand
however I've already got some JV
partners that are interested in in doing
it and potentially managing it for me as
well
so yes potentially I could spend the 20
grand but actually if I get them
involved and I'm probably spending more
around I mean the the key to business is
to keep your costs down yeah so if you
can keep your costs down and keep more
money in your bank for contingencies for
other projects and still make similar
money tomorrow money it's the key is
that it's the key you know I think that
refurb project actually taught me
lessons going into this this whole
business plan thing with JV partners
when you're like well if it was your own
money would you actually spend that
amount of money and I was like I
wouldn't first thing it's going to
happen in Cambridge is actually these
guys the camera crew on camera crew
they're actually going to stay in one of
my service accommodation places are they
yeah so it's got to be better than the
Ibis isn't it guys so they're going to
stay there and hopefully tell me any
pitfalls or anything that's going wrong
with it already like that but sorry
they're going to stay there and I'm
gonna meet them there in the morning
filming in in that one and then I'm
gonna take them to another one that's
literally just across the road and then
they're gonna meet my mine and
granddad's
which means quite interesting because my
mom and dad are sworn in it up in the
Sun and then we're gonna go over I'm
going to show them bit Cambridge and
around and then we're gonna see the fire
department so basically the guys gonna
have road or so and yes for the day yeah
free a free night staying in a
two-bedroom house and central Cambridge
they're loving life loving life so we
asked this question to you last week and
you mentioned your partner yeah about
how it's not just about you Samuel is a
big advocate or that the money is not
just for you it's not just about what
the money does for you it's about what
it does for other people so what's your
underlying sort of Y in reasoning for
getting involved in property and and
sort of starting now embarking on this
journey yeah easy to be honest with you
I mean one of the main reasons is 100%
is Cori and because we both lived well
she still does to a certain extent 95
works very hard but she's also and she
plays football and at quite a high level
but she has to work full time for us to
be able to pay bills and play football
so for instance the other day they
played Oxford away and she got back at
1:00 a.m. in the morning and then she
was back at work at 9 o'clock in the
morning she is a like sports coach and
my main motivator without a doubt is to
provide a better life for both herself
and me and if I can make that money
through property whereby she can help me
with property because she's pretty tech
savvy on media on the media front if I
can give her an extra income to do that
then that will change her life it will
change mine let's join Hana taking a
look around some property she'd be
looking at refurbishing in Cambridge
Hanna's business plan has multiple arms
to it including serviced accommodation
releasing equity from her own house and
the end goal of building a large
buy-to-let portfolio
I'm looking at our football everything's
been completely ripped out and this is
actually the living room it's based on
three floors these new windows new
Claude pepper seniors pretty good and
unfortunately just miss the building
John came around reckons that probably
do it for around about 1550 and a half K
which is fantastic
I'll give you a quick tour of the house
if you
[Music]
okay so we're in sunny Cambridge at the
moment unlike royal yesterday and this
is one of my subscribers units which we
provide at battle craft and center and
this is a two-bedroom house and coming
up quickly what I'll show you downstairs
is currently and Matt is upstairs no
cameramen they finally stayed it last
night big up some kitchen garden goes
out a sense for Cambridge okay so we're
at the property in Cambridge which is
the first my business plan which is the
five apartment service accommodation
apartments so as you can see still
burning building and and we're gonna
meet the landlord and what they've done
they've actually walk guard context
don't it's hype that's really really
cool
and it's set to be finished in the
middle of June so were solving tearing
stuff this should be really cool so I'm
go Tyler I take a look I'm excited I've
never seen a plot
[Music]
[Music]
so when you market with your market its
members every cup seems minimizing - a
placement for the other really cool
thing is the fact that they are managed
[Music]
sign as well so yeah middle of June
maybe July it's great actually in the
summer season he's gonna make he's gonna
make a lot money I'm excited let's catch
up with Hanna's nearest and dearest so
we can get a flavor of how bloody
awesome she is she kind of came home one
day and was like oh I'm gonna start
renting this place in Cambridge and I'm
gonna put it out with a B&B and I was
like alright okay I was like in time
when she was like no no I'm gonna do it
now and I was like like right now she's
like yeah I'm gonna gonna get it all
sorted so she went home went to
Cambridge got it all sorted and did it
and I was a bit like oh like this all
done she took care so it was like okay
great
and then obviously she's got like
another one for me and then with all the
other stuff a little bit new business
and that she takes a lot of things to
heart which is quite an emotional person
she doesn't really show it that much but
he like if someone says anything bad
about her or negative she really takes
to heart so I think that it's a big like
I think as well with like everything
she's done I think she's come across a
lot of that and she's kind of got over
it which has been good for her as well
because I think with their work in day
to day she's always been really good at
that and comfortable so I think she's
never really had it with him work but
now she's gone into this which is a
little bit different
I think she's overcome quite a lot of
negative things she's good
because like obviously when she worked
in bris
still she worked nine to five but she
would leave the house really only get
home really late like I play football so
I train three nights a week I caught one
night so I don't get into like half ten
so you wouldn't really see each other
four nights a week but then obviously
with this now it's a bit more freedom so
like perhaps if I've got an hour after
work before I go train then go home and
she's always there so like that's a good
thing then let's come out of here doing
a different job is that we do sometimes
get a little bit more time to spend
together which is nice but then
obviously with her being away with the
show and things and like if she's got to
go Cambridge on the weekend and things
like that if I'm working I can't really
go with her so I don't see it then but I
think it weighs up that I probably do
see her more which is it's bad I think
Hannah's biggest strength is that she's
she's very committed to something she'll
go with it and she's very driven and
she's hard-working and yeah and she's
sees things suit to the end as well
she's driven she's very likable she's
she's silly
she's warm-hearted she's somebody who
she's got a softness about that I can't
explain here like she's normal
she's somebody that that anybody could
look at she's coming from a
working-class background she's a mean
able to any situation she speaks to
everybody exactly the same how she finds
them and and yeah I don't think anybody
deserves more than her and obviously I'm
biased but she's worth so much into a
career even if it's not the property
side over the last 20 20 years she's
worked so hard and nobody deserves to be
where she is today what Hannah we didn't
understand it we're not into this air
B&B is it or where it is and we didn't
quite understand what was going on at
first and then she's explained it to us
and she's and every time we say you know
how's it going she said oh my god it's a
lot more flats so more things that
turned it we've got a little bit nervous
I must have bit thinking oh you know it
going to be out of her depth which
certainly hasn't been especially at a
very young age 26
so she's no she's time very well yep
we're really proud of her she is very
very focused and what she wants to want
to achieve that's you know okay she said
you've always said to the kids if you
sometimes have to work with people you
don't particularly like just smile and I
think possibly she made probably didn't
like all of her people who competing
against her but she doesn't actually
outwardly show it she just you know but
she is very very focused she would like
to do we didn't understand what it was
about first of all but we do now and
she's done very well I said in my
business plan I'm an ordinary person
trying to do extraordinary things which
I think it's quite a powerful message
because there's a lot of people out
there but don't have any money but don't
think they can make money or they feel
that they're stuck in a nine-to-five job
and they can't do anything it's crap
it's bollocks if you've got Drive and
you've got determination you can make
waves in the world doing whatever you
want to do whether it's free property or
charity or whatever but I would say you
only have one life you 100% a half to
live it and the reason why I have that
is my my dad had cancer recently he
overcame it and it changes your mindset
if you're sitting on the seat right now
and you're watching this and you're
wondering whether to get into or not
dive straight in for kids it's changed
my life I'm 26 and I will now forever be
working for myself in some sort capacity
doing what I want to do hopefully one
day traveling the world and do you know
I can genuinely say that I'm the
happiest I've ever been mentally as well
so
and just just go ahead and do it and I'd
say one of the other things I'm really
proud about is 100% doing it as a as a
gay person as well in I guess in the
mainstream in the media and I'm being
proud about it I'm not ashamed about it
and I think it's I think it's a cool
thing and I hope people take
encouragement and confidence from it
that it's not what you are it's what you
do
good luck Han we saw proud but we
couldn't be any folder where you going
final then we all do every other day
love you good luck Carlo oh really well
I'm really really proud of you
good luck Hannah I know you'll do well
and I hope you win the final I used to
say too when they playing football that
when two players are running for the
ball it's classed as a 50/50 but you
just say to her it's not 5050 you have
to say to yourself it's mine
[Music]
all weeks of intense competition
complete hours of property deals
negotiated but who will take home
Samuels 20,000 pounds in the final
boardroom this is probably the most
nervous I've been out this whole thing I
think - so - because I feel it's a bit
out of my hands so with all the tasks
and things because they were sort of
like effort driven and there's an
element of control but with this there's
there's nothing it just comes down to
who they think has the best business
plan and so yeah I'm pretty nervous I'm
laughing because that's what I do
in these situations but yeah I am pretty
nervous I'm just about to go into the
boardroom and I'm super nervous but
super excited I think everything has led
me to this point today and I've come to
win so I'm going to go in there and do
everything I can and just show - Samuel
and the team exactly what I've been
doing since I left the castle and I
really hope that they pick me to win the
20,000 pounds
okay so you anything Anthony yep
you went to see Hannah yeah what did you
think of Hannah awesome really very good
I think my plans good so we went to
visit our old employer which he trained
to be a solicitor and they absolutely
love Dylan now they were very
complementary that they said how hard
work ages and they always knew she'd be
a success and so when when she left when
she handed a note saying they knew she'd
gone to do good things she's a bright
girl that's for sure the question is do
you think that where she's going to be
putting the money do you think that it's
a gonna be a very strong solid
investment I do think it comes with some
risks because obviously service
accommodation is the buzzword at the
minute we all know what happens when
things on the buzz was they said depend
to go a little bit wrong sometimes you
don't want to look well our concerns may
be with her plan it she's not actually
buying anything so we were Antony's plan
he's buying a property so at least he's
got that as an asset whereas we're doing
rent two rents previously putting all
the money into deposits and mainly
furniture why grow
tell me about till about and to Luke
okay so antes plan is obviously to do
buy refurbish refinance it's been
working really hard this week going out
do lots of viewings first we're not when
I went out I was a bit surprised that he
was pricing the work up on his own
because obviously you want an accurate
quote having said that having spoken to
him I think he does know what he's
talking about looking around the house
he's got a very good idea of how much
things cost do you think there's a
chance that would buy refurbish
refinance if he's banking on being able
to pull his money out I mean but but
what's the worst that's what I'm saying
if he doesn't pull his money out he
still owns the house yeah he's still got
an asset asset whereas if Hannah's
doesn't work she's got nothing so let's
just see Hannah does far as service
accommodation and then in six months the
the rules change and the vanes done the
vendor says through bring him in yeah
let's get him in
yeah hey guys feelin good so how have
you done Hanna and I think I've done
okay I think and last week yeah it was
last week we went round the five
apartments got to see them they not only
finished now until mid June and there's
slight setback in the construction but
we got some really good footage with
landlady she's gonna basically let me
choose the design of the the apartments
and things and fully furnish it - what
kind of what do you think my biggest
concern is with you with me as a person
well all the business and all your plan
I think my plan is riskier than
Anthony's and because it involves
service accommodation and it involves
units that aren't currently ready at the
moment and so that's a risk in itself
and I'd probably say that's your biggest
concern mm-hmm and tonight what do you
think my biggest concern with you is
that I probably can able to analyze
things a little bit too much and and I
know last time when we're in the
boardroom I put too much detail in the
business plan we put Jim is deep man it
was a terrible plan wasn't to detailed
it just sucked okay so what do you think
my concern is of you now I think without
seeing what I've done you concern would
be that if you give me the 20,000 pound
that I won't invest it correctly yeah
well I mean we have seen what you've
done to a point and then Russell's been
out with you what are you thinking it
all fairness on today he was seemed it
seems to know what he's talking about
when look at the property he's got a
very good idea of how much the jobs are
to be done he's got a pretty good eye
for a spot spot in the right viewings
and finding the right sort of house this
so I think that from what I've seen I'm
very interested in seeing his finished
results but from what I've seen
I think he's got a pretty good idea of
what to do so where are you planning on
buying Anthony so I've looked at
properties in Crewe and stow if you've
got a particular property or you just
got a general plan now I've got two
properties that are secured okay show me
yes to have any anything move you know
would you mind if I've got them out all
right okay so this is a property that
I've secured in Crewe
so it's on the market for 70,000 pounds
I've secured it for 60 I initially went
in there expecting the works to be at
12,000 pound I already like the look of
this but I've since had quotes on all
the work and with a contingency of 20%
I've got the refurb cost down to eight
thousand seven hundred and seventy eight
pounds is that from our build or is up
so basically the quotes for that are all
build works to be done by a professional
builder
I've also then put in for most of the
weight to be project managed by myself
but then also put in 1,400 pounds labor
costs for a local labor merchant that I
use to cover hundred pound the day so 14
days worth of work are you going to be
hands-on with the project management and
stuff yes for this one yes and I've seen
that you're very good at refurbs because
you had it in the challenge this this
house cuz I've been around this house
it's very much cosmetics it looks
terrible when you were looking beautiful
to make it I mean I'm impressed
do you know what I like Anthony is on I
think the third task we asked you to
write a business plan and you gave us a
30 page business plan you've taken on
the feedback that we gave you about that
and you've know presented us with our
six or seven page plan yeah top job very
it's a good business you factory don't a
lot as well
hello let me ask you a question I mean
it's a good business plan you know
Anthony you've worked with him you know
his strategy why do you think what do
you see any Falls in this no I think I
think I think it's very I think it's a
safer strategy than the one that I'm
adopting in terms of the fact that he's
actually investing his money in capital
appreciation but one thing that I would
say
is that my business plan is
interchangeable so Anthony's business
plan is focused on buying a property
tell me tell me about your business plan
to me then so in my business plan
mainly is factored into three steps the
first step is basically to acquire
service accommodation units use it as a
cash cow to invest money in Cambridge
right that's in Cambridge got them I
mean I can't Chris I his Hannah to be
honest when I was with Hannah
it was everything was good probably too
immaculately but the property's secured
their secured Soria yeah yeah so the
five parts mine is in a brand new
building so I basically get the whole
building there five studio apartments
how many parts in the whole building for
life yeah and you've got all five five
yeah and you're renting them yeah and
how much rent are you paying for the
five of them five thousand pounds five
thousand five thousand thousand per unit
and you're obviously the lease the
mortgage has all been checked you cover
all fine so I actually use this other
landlord for one of my other service
accommodation okay and the yeah you
you've done this before yes so the the
reason why I say mine is interchangeable
is because actually since being in the
castle and do my business plan my step
one was do a whole basically invest much
the money in the service accommodation
used myself actually we considered that
now and I'm potentially going to get JV
partner in so I put in less money and
potentially that JV partner is going to
manage them for me as well okay so I'll
actually have I'm spending half the
money and then the other half the money
will allow me to basically move on step
two a lot quicker and step two is finish
refer being my actual home residents
remortgage it so I can pull out a lot of
money from it because I actually bought
that below market value in 2017 which I
haven't had the money to default it's a
little bit too all over the place that
isn't it not sure I appreciate that but
I genuinely think that the business plan
that I've put in front of you you can
generate more income show me the
business plan limit I don't have my
business plan on me now it just doesn't
look great no I completely appreciate
that and I understand that I thought
that when we handed them in they'd be
here but that's my fault I take that on
the chin
you thought what I
I thought that they thought they'd be
here when when we left them at the
castle that's my fault
you've also changed their business place
it's interchangeable yeah but you've got
a new idea which is actually I'm gonna
do this whole thing with my house
have you written that down you've got
this on the business plan yet I'll step
to actually 80 which is it stayed
exactly the Train exactly saying all I'm
saying is I could accelerate it if I
wanted to so if you're not brought have
you not brought with you the figures for
the house that you'll want us to you
know like this as in my actual house the
figures in the wall or anything any
evidence of what you're going to
actually what do you mean doing the last
two weeks of the business one's the
exact same what have I been doing so
I've been making sure that the
apartments are when they're going to be
ready and to view them and making sure
that everything's agreed for them and
what I'm going to do in terms of
management agents and things like that
threatening struggle is the fact that
you you know you've seen hunting these
pets you've heard his business plan and
you've said yes and this is really good
yes yes mines risky yes mines all over
the place it's not it's all over the
place I think my plan is very clear it
hasn't changed all I'm saying is the
fact that it's interchangeable and the
fact that I can accelerate my step my
year one to my year two that's all I'm
saying because like you know chefs
accommodation is slightly risky I'm
saying I can buy some of that risk back
by JV by JV partnering I know what I'm
doing with service accommodation I know
that it will work I know the figures
because I run a studio apartment that's
not too far from there it makes a lot of
profit and I know that this will work
and in terms of the return on investment
of the money that you're going to give
me I know that my return on investment
will be higher than Anthony's business
plan the reason why I need the 20,000
pounds is because in order to take this
20 percent off him it costs me money
so it's either cost me a return if I
give him a percentage back which would
be 12% etc etc or in this particular
case it's 50 percent so it's a joint
venture fifty percent of the property
I'm happy to do this because capital
appreciation I'll get it in the long
term but what I want to do is build a
portfolio for myself so maybe love Lila
through my question use waffling just to
clarify
between them you've just confused me as
well so we're gonna give you twenty
thousand pound if you win what are you
going to use that twenty five thousand
pound for because you've just told
you've got a JV partners gonna pay for
the the the buying costs designers for
the rest so would you doubt 20k for to
buy that household this house
those who I've found to use on both
houses but if we don't give you money
you'll still buy one that's correct
right okay if you have a look at this
house boys yes of course which one would
you buy you just bought one I would buy
that one I think is and I don't want to
have to argue Hannah's case for her but
you're saying with your twenty grand its
can have really helped me because I'm
gonna be able to buy one more house
you've already got a house that you've
done this strategy with no money down
you've just got a second one which
you've got no money down and you want a
third house which is which makes me feel
like I'm gonna slot
I want to skyrocket someone twenty
thousand pound is a lot of money one of
you will leave this building with twenty
thousand pounds in your bank and I'm
just feeling potentially that would mean
more to hammer than it would tear why do
you think that sorry because you write
your about you're about to buy two
houses this month but if I don't give
you any money you're still buy one but
no doubt by next week you'll have raised
the money yourself anyway although I've
secured this joint venture partner I
still haven't signed the agreement I'm
quite quite weight stacked in your favor
you were like yeah I've got the
agreement and now he's but actually I
haven't signed the document is it yeah
I'm confident I've got this joint
venture partner but like I said for me
this twenty thousand pound means the
difference between you know growing my
business the way I'd like to grow it no
this isn't going to help you much it's
just gonna slightly improve I think this
is just very nice to Antony what you
gonna be successful anyway so we're not
going to help you the bottom is because
my my strategy for these houses the
reason why I've looked for these
particular houses in these areas is
because I have multiple strategies with
them strategy one is to hold it if I use
an investor because it leaves six
thousand pound in there what I don't
want to do is squander that twenty
thousand pound that you you that are you
know that you would give me what I'd
like to do is use that effectively I
know you said buying right now isn't the
right thing to do but both of these
areas I've selected because the buying
market of the area is really high so
I'll
refurbish the house sell the house make
a profit on it and be able to to buy
more houses and and until I find a house
guess you're right profit I'm looking at
your numbers here on the fifty six
thousand pound house so this is the
second when you just gave us yeah you've
got the purchase cost at thirty thousand
one hundred negative pounds can you just
break that bone quickly because that
seems awfully high for purchasing costs
that's the fifty thousand pound on the
bridge inputs the the refurbishment
costs okay so that's not purchase cost
and as a because then you've also got
our separate length of renovation costs
could you only get okay nowhere so the
perching cost that's the full cost of
when it's deducted at the end the reef
ocean cost about in the second line just
because it's in the second but that
purchased cost includes the
refurbishment souls the fifty six
thousand pound property how much the how
much we're going to need to actually buy
that house forget reefer with a minute
so just to buy the house just to finance
it and buy up how much is like wouldn't
be to find out some buyer yes excluding
the refurb because we favor children is
built into the bridging finance on that
one can you can I just want the answer
so like fifty six thousand pound house
yeah how much is the deposit and the
legal cost to buy that house so it
doesn't have to be to the pound I'm just
talking about an approximate because
that you've got dunya thirty eight
thousand but that seems high for that's
one of twenty thousand permits in the
purchase price that's so with the
bridging obviously I will have to put in
a higher percentage how much thirty five
percent on bridge okay and then I was
thirty five percent of fifty six
thousand that's at eighteen nineteen and
then the remainder of it what's that
thirty and then plus the refurbishment
on top of it brings it to that figure
thirty-eight sums york outspent right
okay i was just you it's just not clear
and here now apologies but but it does
the figures do idle i'm sure i'm sure
they do but it's just not very clear on
here but yeah okay thank you okay this
isn't very very quickly Hanley I don't
feel you've given me much really okay I
disagree with you give me a huge
opportunity I think if you gave me this
twenty thousand pounds it would
genuinely change my life because
not only will it propel me in property
and it will bring me an income and it
will completely change my lifestyle to
where I am right now the business plan
I've given you is a business plan that
will make me a lot of income very
quickly it will use your money very
efficiently and it will generate a
higher ROI I don't think by Anthony
buying two houses will change his life I
don't think that amount of money will
change his life that drastically I think
that his business plan is very good and
I think it's very safe and I do think
mine's riskier but I think that mine the
twenty thousand pounds will change my
life I don't think it would change
Anthony's and I think that when you see
what I can do with it and where I'll be
in 12 months time I think you'll agree
with it and hopefully after seeing me in
the way that I've operated in the fact
that I wasn't in any boardroom I didn't
lose on any team throughout this whole
process will hopefully give you a good
indication of a person I am and that
your money would be safe from very well
invested I know why why is this 20,000
pounds so important to you now I
understand about change much less what
they through what will it change in your
life freedom it gives me it gives me
freedom with with my family look I think
people have different goals in life my
my goals are to make memories and share
experiences for people but I love them
people that are around me and in order
to do that any time
but things cost money so I need four I
need four things be paid and property
gives me that machine to do that so I've
got family members that work around the
clock for very little money and it's
hard it's really hard watching them
suffer when I could possibly give them
an out with the information I've got in
my head with a bit of a helping hand and
if I can change their lives through a
bit of action of what I do then that
lasts an unbelievable thing that have an
impact you know one thing that I'm
actually a little bit disappointed with
the day is I came to your employers yeah
I believe that's where you qualified it
was yeah and they spoke so highly of you
yeah this books so highly about your
organizational skills and the one thing
that disappoints me you didn't come here
I know that's the one thing that
disappoints me today yeah no I
completely understand that and yeah I
completely understand I'm disappointed
in the fact that I didn't bring it I'm
terribly sorry about that I can only
apologize but I can only only hope that
like I said you know me throughout the
process you've asked me about my
business plan the figures you've seen me
you've seen the stuff that I showed the
cameramen have seen the potential it's
the business plan Scott
and I truly think that what you think no
matter what we do there goes you're both
going to be super successful and you
don't need the 20,000 pound in pass that
knowledge on to you your family and
today you can probably see the passion
in Hannah and that this will be a
life-changing thing for I just don't I
just don't get that from you at all okay
for me this twenty thousand pound isn't
just for me you know the purpose of why
I want to do this strategy it's because
I want to build houses for people to
live in I've just you know that the you
know the the disgusting house that we
went into people were living in that
house and that's why I want to refurb
these to this quality and that's why the
twenty thousand pound will change my
life because it's not just for me it's
for the other people that I'm going to
put in these houses you know what I
don't I don't I don't buy that at all
but it is good that this is it's no it's
not
you know money doesn't make my world go
around but being able to do something
with it does so does that mean you're
gonna do a heavily discounted rent to
these people no because people pay the
rent in the area for the quality of the
house that's there and I'm going to
provide them quality of housing for
people why do you worry why do you care
about why do I care because I have been
in that situation I've been in that
situation where I have had nothing and
I've been put in a house it's disgusting
we've mold on the wall you know and my
landlord didn't care about me you know
and and that's where that's where people
are I go into these houses all the time
you know and then when people say Oh
somebody's living in this house and
you're like nobody's living in this
house because this house is disgusting
so I want to change that for people you
know all these things that keep changing
with the laws and landlords and things
like that that's fine
because I'll be better than them people
and I'll provide houses for people for
years to come because we are becoming a
nation of renter's you know people
haven't got the opportunity to buy a
house anymore they're not presented with
opportunities like this whether it might
change their lives and have them money
to buy houses but I am so I'm going to
use it properly you know and change
people's lives John I see from you hands
now
if you've got your actual business panel
you've got these I've got the business
plan okay one thing I want to know from
you is rather than just these two houses
have you got a strategy in place for as
you're pulling money out you're
reinvesting it into houses yeah so what
you so my long-term plan for these
houses was in the first year I aimed to
to flip three of these houses because if
I could take between ten and fifteen
thousand pound out of three houses that
means I've then got some more money to
use the second year so I can then buy
and hold and I can build a portfolio
very quickly - what's my aim in in in
the end of the three years is to have a
portfolio of 20 houses and I think I can
do that with this strategy okay yeah as
interesting disease then it was more
like a by refurbished fires
business as opposed to I'm just buying -
I'm not just buying two houses you know
I'm building a portal tell me what you
think of hammers plan
I think Hannah's plan is risky I have
serviced accommodation and I know the
market is extremely risky I know the
market changes quite fluidly although I
know Hannah is very skilled at what she
does and if she says it will work you
know and these essays will make money
and I'm confident that it'll might be
better off given another point I don't
think that at all I think that my
business plan is very strong you know
and I think Hannah's business plan is
very strong I think I can see it sorry
if we could say yeah can I look at your
business but yes so let me ask you
Antony would you invest in Hannah's
business idea right now now if you had
20,000 pounds right now you know I've
put two thousand poem because you're
asking us for it but if you had twenty
thousand pound and you're looking for an
investment do you think Hannah's
business would be a good idea to a good
investment
personally I wouldn't and the reason why
is because I would you invest in
Anthony's business plan if I had 20
thousand pounds forgetting yourselves
combination side of things if you're an
investor like Samuel Simas number
we do invest in anthony's business plan
it would depend on the return on
investment and to what you've returned
an investment so it's 53 percent on the
one with alpha then yeah it looks like a
good business plan I mean I think the
thing is obviously the 20,000 pound that
I'm gonna give one of you today is a
gift it's not an investment you could
say but at the same time although it's
it's no strings attached of course I
want to see I want to see as much change
as I can I'm an investor so well I'm not
gonna be getting a financial gain from
it I'll be getting a satisfaction gain
should we have a few minutes to have a
chat and call that pulling back in but
as I say before you leave the building
today one of you will be 20,000 pound
richer so if you give us a few minutes
I'd be great Thank You Hannah
I am scared about her plan yeah yeah a
little bit I think you know so quickly
and well I don't know no I don't know I
am a bit scared that's your pissy of the
wall I really rate her I think she's a
very competent person I'm just I'm just
not sure
Anthony's I'm very sure and I'm very
confident in but it's just not as
exciting yeah it's boring isn't and I
just I'd love to see I'm away Hannah's
you only need 10 grand what pisses me
off minute about Hannah is where the
where the figures but that does where's
my pictures of the other thing what's
she been doing the whole point of this
was you get together you go and do the
work and then Yuri edit your business
plan based on what you've learned and
bring in each but nothing I mean Anthony
is very prepared
I'm very enjoy what's really good is
heat it the nice neat I can't see right
now how you could not give it to an
tonight
I think but Hannah's plan is the cash
flows can come a lot quicker so the
return investments going to come much
much quicker if it comes yeah it's a
risk what sort of families Fantas
probably don't get buried up danger zone
as a proper zone it's good change
Hannah's life
Hannah really wants this is hard come
from
so I thought this mean you're saying
that you can't you can't say you're
gonna be you're gonna be successful
anyway so I okay well they're both gonna
be successful anyway you got are you you
can write money you're also anyway so
I'm not gonna give you the win you don't
make you the winner
cuz you I said what would you do in my
situation right now if I was you I would
personally give it to her cause you
wouldn't get the money back quicker well
I'm not gonna get any money back no and
okay then based on would get their money
back quicker the mundi we go further
their money's gonna go far they mean I
think it means a lot more to Hannah
Antony's already proved he can raise
money yep listen that out
you can't award the winner of the show
based on who you think it's gonna be
once it more I both really want it for
the process the both want it but I
wouldn't balance it more does better in
life if you clearly over the same
there's no problem then Anthony clearing
once it bothers me because he's business
planning is better in fairness because
he bought specifying yeah yeah but is he
by far I think Anthony's is the safest
absolutely because he will be won in the
aerosol I like to be a little bit of a
risk-taker
okay I think I'm yeah
[Music]
hi-yah hi-yah Abby can you come through
to the boardroom please thank you can
you please send 20,000 pounds across to
this account thank you
[Music]
it's not been an easy decision and today
you've impressed us with your with your
with your proposal Hannah you're clearly
very very competent one of you is gonna
walk away with 20,000 pounds do you
think you should be you on tonight yes
how did you think it should be a hundred
percent how do you feel right now very
nervous why because what comes out in
your mouth can drastically change the
course of my life and to know how do you
feel I can feel my heart going on mile
an hour because everything's led up to
this and I think I've grown and
developed and then just want to be able
to do even more so like and I said this
is gonna change one of our lives without
the money the process of the eviction
well how is that going to help you it's
it's helped me develop massively as a
person the business plan that I
presented to you everything everything
in now when I was contemplating it
there's all stages of things have
happened through the eviction so it's
really helped me grow as a person and
I'm gonna be forever thankful for that
how about you Hannah yeah knowledge and
confidence like the the particular tasks
where we had to go out and find no money
down deals lease options I've never
touched them before and the confidence
to literally go out there and go direct
to estate agents and ask for things like
that and the relationships that I've
built with the other contestants I mean
a couple of us potentially may may even
go into business with each other further
down the line which is which is really
cool I mean I think you're both
extremely strong and we we were even
talking about oh my goodness could we
just give it to both of you know because
you're both fantastic and whatever
happens moving forward you're both gonna
receive a lot of help and support from
us both personally and you know in every
way possible really and because we're
really rooting for you and we were
actually pretty told well we
yeah that was the the longest and
hardest decision what we what were you
thinking I've been chewing and throwing
I went into the media thinking one thing
change on my change back
but you were leading afterwards you
willing in towards Antony and you were
leading to a Tanner but ultimately I've
had to make the decision and as joyful
as it is giving away twenty thousand
pounds to somebody it's also really hard
not giving it to somebody so Hannah
Congrats you've got through to the final
and today you've won my trust because I
wasn't convinced when you said about the
tenants but I think I am now the
question is who have I decided to
transfer my twenty thousand pound money
to Abby is the money actually in the
account so right now has been twenty
thousand pound transferred into entities
account but relations thank you so much
thank you
thank you that's amazing thank you so
much and I really appreciate the help
that you guys have given me along the
journey and I won't let you down with
this you know it's gonna be amazing to
show you
what I get to do with this Hana great
effort you've been a fantastic
contestant and we're going to support
you and work with you Anthony well done
thank you congratulations
what is earth thank you thank you madam
good job
I think so I was really appreciative
what ok mother
[Applause]
yeah Jinora is yeah go on it's it's
emotional because when you feel like you
got the waiting I think it was a good
result in in for Anthony and he's a very
deserving winner the problem I got is
were too super strong candidates they've
also got very different business plans
ultimately you know I like assets so I I
do think Anthony probably was the edge
did just a little bit and Ohana's might
bring in more cash but I fundamentally
like asset so I think that is the the
more deserving winner if in this case so
just one twenty thousand pound I cannot
believe it on absolutely over the moon
where we're in the boardroom and Samuel
was asking questions about the business
plan of why I deserved the twenty
thousand pound I did think there was a
moment that Hannah would one you know
and I would have been so pleased for
about I just knew what this meant to me
so happy I just can't explain it I think
how is absolutely fantastic and Hannah
and I have already discussed that we're
gonna do some business together outside
of this so we've got some opportunities
that we're gonna work on I think she's
been a great candidate and the whole way
through this process it's been great to
see her in the finals and I couldn't
have asked for a better person to be
there in the final with me although it's
made it extremely tough because had some
of the weaker been there then you know I
would have won quite easily it was a
tough decision but at the end of the day
I do think that Anthony deserved to win
but there were some such strong
candidates and
I was so close but ultimately I think I
made the right decision and that was
brutal but genuinely really happy for
Anthony and I say this because he's a
really really good guy and there's a
couple of other people that I would have
been a little bit more disappointed
about if I were genuine if I would have
lost in the final but he's he's a good
guy and I didn't really know him for
this actually he's actually one of my
friends now without a doubt and we're
actually JV and on a really cool thing
that we found and when were on the
eviction it's brutal
it's horrible this feeling at the moment
but it's nicer in a way to know that
he's won so there is a silver lining
turning away because although it feels
horrible at the moment at this moment in
time he's a really great guy and
genuinely pleased for him his business
plan was epic and he pulled out the bag
massively over like the last week mine
pretty much say the same but his
business plan that came in there with
and he's ROI and things like that and
Sam you even asked me ask me would I
invest in it and I would I would say
this is the beginning of a bigger
journey so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
throughout the eviction process you've
seen 13 people on their journey to
financial freedom and I'm very
passionate about helping people which is
why I train thousands of people every
single year to become property investors
so if you'd like to become a property
investor then you can join me at the
property investors crash course which is
a free program where you can learn the
skills to start your journey to
financial freedom
[Music]
[Music]